Spartacus: The Slave Who Made Rome Tremble
According to legend, Spartacus’s wife walked
in on her sleeping husband one night to find
that a snake had wrapped itself around his
face.
Instead of being alarmed, she took this as
a prophecy.
Just like the serpent surrounded itself around
the warrior’s head, so shall Spartacus be
enveloped by a “great and fearful power”.
One thing the woman could not see, however,
was if this power would lead her husband to
glory or disaster.
In the end, you will have to decide for yourself
what the outcome was.
Spartacus might have lost the war, sure, but
not before making the all-powerful Roman Republic
tremble at his feet.
At a time when the might of Rome was continuously
expanding all over the Mediterranean, a mere
slave led an uprising the likes of which the
world had never seen.
He defeated wave after wave of Roman armies
and looked, for a while at least, powerful
enough to march on Rome itself.
His actions turned Spartacus into much more
than a warrior.
He became a symbol in the fight against oppression.
A symbol which is still pervasive today, over
2,000 years later.
They say that history is written by the victors
so, in that case, Spartacus’s omen was,
indeed, one of glory.
Nobody mentions the success of Crassus in
putting down a slave uprising.
Instead, they talk about the triumph and the
bravery of Spartacus.
Early Years
Unsurprisingly, details are scarce regarding
Spartacus’s life before he rose up and became
the bane of Rome.
Even the particulars we do know cannot be
taken for granted because different ancient
sources give varying accounts.
Image suggestion: Spartacus statue
Everyone seems to agree that Spartacus was
a Thracian born sometime around the year 111
BCE.
Plutarch, one of the main sources for the
“War of Spartacus”, as he called it, referred
to the warrior as having “nomadic stock”
and described him as being sagacious and culturally
superior, practically “more Hellenic than
Thracian”.
Some modern scholars have speculated that
the word “nomadic” was a mistranslation
made later and that Plutarch, actually, referred
to Spartacus of being of “Maedi stock”.
The Maedi were a Thracian tribe from those
times which existed in modern-day Bulgaria.
Eventually, Spartacus ended up fighting in
the Roman army as an auxiliary unit.
At one point, the Thracian earned the scorn
of the Romans who captured him and sold him
into slavery.
Again, sources vary as to the reason why - some
say that Spartacus deserted, others that he
led raiding parties, or, perhaps, both.
Life as a Slave
As a slave, Spartacus caught the eye of one
Lentulus Batiatus, a Roman who owned a gladiator
school called a “ludus” in Capua.
He was always on the lookout for strong Gauls
and Thracians who could shed some blood for
the pleasure of the crowd.
Image suggestion: Murmillo
In the arena, Spartacus took on the role of
a heavyweight gladiator called a “murmillo”.
The look of this warrior is a Hollywood favorite
and will be familiar to anyone who saw or
played anything set in gladiator times.
The murmillo wore a full bronze helmet and
heavy arm, leg, or shoulder guards.
However, he kept his chest bare which often
allowed warriors to display the tattoos or
battle scars they accrued over the years.
The gladiator typically wielded a large shield
called a “scutum” and a straight broadsword
called a “gladius”.
Although Spartacus has always been depicted
in movies and TV shows as a prodigious fighter,
we actually do not know anything about his
success in the arena.
Since these battles were usually to the death,
he was, presumably, skilled enough to survive
until the uprising started.
Either that or he was entertaining enough
to convince the crowd to spare him, even if
he lost.
The Start of the Uprising
In the year 73 BCE, Spartacus was part of
a plot to escape Batiatus’s gladiator school.
The number differs - Plutarch says 78 slaves
armed themselves with utensils from the kitchen,
defeated the guards and made a run for it.
During their escape, they ran into carts full
of gladiator weapons being sent to another
city.
They plundered the wagons and armed themselves
properly.
The former slaves decided to seek refuge on
Mount Vesuvius which offered a stronger defensive
position.
On their way there, they recruited other slaves,
as well as freemen who wanted to join their
cause.
Ancient sources never really made it clear
what exactly Spartacus did or said to the
other slaves to convince them that he should
be their leader.
One factor which certainly played a part was
the fact that the men split all their plunder
equally.
But it should be mentioned that historians
also named two Gauls - Crixus and Oenomaus
- as leaders of the revolt.
While some described them as being the equals
of Spartacus, others like Appian referred
to them as subordinate officers.
The Battle of Mount Vesuvius
It is fair to say that when the Roman Senate
heard about Spartacus and his little uprising,
they did not take it too seriously.
We may mock them for it now but, back then,
this made some sense.
Rome had quite a few other problems on its
hands that required its attention and, more
importantly, its soldiers.
In the Iberian Peninsula, Rome was engaged
in the Sertorian War against Quintus Sertorius,
a former Roman statesman who chose the losing
side during the Second Civil War of the Roman
Republic, but refused to concede defeat.
Over in Asia Minor, Rome was fighting the
Third Mithridatic War against the Kingdom
of Pontus led by Mithridates VI.
This eventually resulted in a decisive victory
for Rome and the end of the Pontic Empire,
but not until ten more years of vicious battles.
As you can see, Rome had its plate full.
Therefore, the revolt of the gladiators was
dismissed as nothing more but a crime wave
that could be solved with a cohort or two.
In charge of this force was a praetor named
Gaius Claudius Glaber of which we know almost
nothing.
His name suggests he could have had some kind
of distant connection with the influential
Claudii family, but, really, his only appearance
in the history record is his battle against
Spartacus.
He is never mentioned again - whether this
means he died in battle or he never did anything
else of note, we just don’t know.
Anyway, Glaber’s army consisted of approximately
3,000 militia, not proper Roman legionaries.
Again, the fact that the Senate sent an unproven
military commander leading untrained militia
revealed how little they were concerned with
this uprising.
Glaber and his units chased the gladiators
to their camp on Mount Vesuvius and laid siege
on the only road down the mountain.
His plan was to simply wait for the insurgents
to starve to death.
It seemed like a fine strategy, albeit a tad
unoriginal.
Spartacus did not have this problem.
In fact, his side deployed a much more novel
game plan.
He knew that Glaber was only paying attention
to the side with the descent because all the
others consisted of steep cliffs which were,
seemingly, impassable.
However, he and his men made rope ladders
out of wild vines that were plentiful in the
area and rappelled down undetected by the
Romans.
They then surrounded Glaber’s camp and easily
defeated his forces in a surprise attack.
In the end, all this expedition managed to
do was to supply the rebels with better weapons
and armor and to help bolster their numbers
as more people heard of their exploits.
The Second Expedition
On the second attempt, Rome sent another praetor
named either Publius Varinius or Publius Valerius.
There are no juicy details to share regarding
these fights.
Just the fact that Spartacus and his men triumphed
again.
First they defeated one of the praetor’s
lieutenants named Furius who had two thousand
soldiers with him.
Then, another praetor called Cossinius who
had been sent out with another large force
to offer support to Varinius.
He was almost taken prisoner by the insurgents
as the gladiators caught his camp off-guard
while the praetor was bathing.
Lastly, the rebels defeated Varinius and,
as a symbol of his victory, Spartacus took
the praetor’s horse.
Now, the gladiator army was free to raid the
countryside of Italy unopposed as more and
more men from the region swelled their ranks.
According to Appian, Spartacus’s army boasted
over 70,000 soldiers.
Presumably, Oenomaus died around this time,
possibly in battle, as he is no longer mentioned
by historians.
Spartacus and Crixus are referred to as the
commanders of the rebel army.
At this point, the insurgents reached a possible
crossroads in their journey, one which still
divides both classical and modern scholars.
According to Plutarch, Spartacus wanted to
traverse the Alps and escape Roman territory.
In his view, the Thracian planned to disband
the army once it had secured freedom.
However, Spartacus could not convince his
men who were feeling cocky enough that they
wanted to continue raiding.
Other sources claimed that the plan was (and
had always been) to march on Rome.
The notion that there was some dissension
in the ranks regarding their next move was
strengthened by the fact that, at one point,
the rebels split into two armies - one was
led by Spartacus, the other by Crixus.
Whether this division was strategic so they
could cover more ground or it was caused by
disagreements, we cannot say with any certainty.
The Death of Crixus
By
this point, the Senate realized that the little
uprising caused by the escaped slaves was
no laughing matter and it was only growing
in power.
Some have argued that the Roman leaders were
reticent to unleash the true might of Rome
because it would have been an admittance of
defeat, in of itself.
Just the idea that a few enslaved Thracians,
Germans, and Gauls could threaten the Roman
Republic was an embarrassment.
But after a year of the rebels running wild,
the Senate had had enough.
In 72 BC, it tasked two consuls, Gellius and
Lentulus, to put an end to the uprising, and
each one commanded a Roman legion.
The exact size of a legion actually varied
throughout the history of Rome.
According to Livy, during the Republic, the
Senate set the size at the start of the year
based on availability and circumstances.
Although typically a legion contained around
4,000 infantry and a few hundred cavalry,
it would vary anywhere between 3,000 and 6,000
soldiers.
Regardless of how many men the legions had,
they were still vastly outnumbered by the
insurgent forces.
However, what they lacked in manpower, they
more than made up for with strict military
training and top-of-the-line equipment.
Spartacus’s forces, on the other hand, consisted
mostly of peasants, deserters, slaves, and
shepherds.
Very few of them stood a chance against a
Roman soldier in combat.
Image suggestion: Roman tortoise formation
Here we arrive at a bit of a contentious moment
because the two main sources, Plutarch and
Appian, give differing accounts on the battles
between Spartacus and the consular armies.
They do not necessarily contradict each other,
but they each mention events that the other
ignores.
As I said previously, the rebel forces split
into two armies.
Both historians agree that Gellius and his
legion fought Crixus who commanded around
30,000 men near Mount Garganus.
This encounter resulted in a decisive victory
for the Romans.
The rebel army lost around two thirds of its
troops, including Crixus who was killed in
battle.
When hearing of this, Spartacus allegedly
sacrificed 300 Roman soldiers in his honor.
Fighting the Consular Armies
Both sources also agree that Spartacus and
the main insurgent force faced the army of
Lentulus while heading for Cisalpine Gaul
and triumphed.
Afterwards, however, they start to differ.
We have to remember that even the best sources
we have for the War of Spartacus wrote their
accounts over 150 years after the uprising
had taken place.
Many details could have been altered or forgotten.
According to Appian, Gellius and his men headed
towards Spartacus after defeating Crixus.
His hope was that he would reach the Spartacan
army in time and trap it between the two legions
commanded by him and Lentulus.
He was too late, though, and the Thracian
had time to best the other consul, turn his
soldiers around and defeat Gellius in combat,
also.
The two consular legions retreated and regrouped
back in Rome.
They then united as a single army and made
a third attempt against Spartacus at Picenum.
They were defeated, once again.
Plutarch makes no mention of Spartacus’s
fight against Gellius or the Battle at Picenum
against both consuls.
Instead, he says that, after the Thracian
bested Lentulus, he engaged in combat with
an army of 10,000 men led by Gaius Cassius
Longinus, the governor of Cisalpine Gaul.
Once again, he was victorious.
There is also some confusion regarding what
happened after Spartacus defeated the consular
armies.
While Plutarch offers no concrete information,
Appian, more or less, places Spartacus on
the warpath to Rome.
Maybe it was the death of Crixus, or maybe
he thought himself invincible in battle, but
Spartacus seemed determined to pillage mighty
Rome itself.
He killed all his prisoners and his pack animals
and set fire to any useless materials that
might have burdened and slowed him down.
He marched on the capital with an army of
120,000 footmen.
Despite his gung-ho attitude, Spartacus had
a change of heart on the way and realized
that, perhaps, his army was not strong enough
just yet.
Instead, he took over the city of Thurii and
the surrounding mountains and conducted raids
for bronze and iron to forge weapons and equip
his troops.
Marcus Licinius Crassus
The Senate dropped any pretense that the Spartacan
rebellion was anything else than a major threat
that endangered the Republic itself.
It gave the task of putting down the uprising
once and for all to Marcus Licinius Crassus.
Image suggestion: Bust of Crassus
Crassus is primarily remembered today for,
allegedly, being the richest man in Roman
history.
The true extent of his wealth is impossible
to gauge with accuracy, but it could have
been up to $20 billion in modern currency.
The number most commonly used is 200 million
sestertii, an estimation provided by Pliny.
Plutarch used gold talents to quantify Crassus’s
wealth and placed it at over 7,100 talents
which would mean, in modern terms, 213 metric
tons of gold.
Crassus’s fortune came from “fire and
war, making the public calamities his greatest
source of revenue”, as Plutarch put it.
Some of his lucrative businesses included
a fire department that arrived at a burning
home and only extinguished the flames if it
negotiated a generous bargain with the owner.
Otherwise, the men simply looked on as the
home burned to the ground.
Afterwards, Crassus even offered to buy the
property (at a significantly-reduced price,
of course).
Another one of his schemes was a school for
slaves.
By taking cheap, unskilled labor and giving
them training, he increased their value significantly
and then sold them on for a tidy profit.
The bulk of Crassus’s wealth, however, came
from real estate.
He was an ally of Sulla, the Roman general
who prompted a Civil War that involved the
aforementioned Quintus Sertorius.
After his triumph, Sulla enacted proscriptions,
meaning that all of his powerful enemies were
either put to death or banished and their
possessions confiscated and put up at auction.
This allowed Crassus to purchase massive amounts
of land and property for next to nothing.
Going back to the war, Crassus was not only
rich, but also had high political aspirations.
He knew that putting down this rebellion would
secure his position in the Senate.
He used his own money to equip and train new
troops.
He was made a praetor and was granted command
of six new legions, plus what was left of
the two consular armies.
The Decimation
At first, it looked like this military expedition
would end like all the others.
While Crassus and the bulk of his army waited
for Spartacus on the borders of Picenum, he
sent his legate, Mummius, with two legions
to circle around and approach the rebellion
army from behind.
Crassus gave explicit orders not to attack
the insurgents or even to engage in skirmishes.
Mummius disobeyed, feeling like he had an
advantageous position.
He attacked and he lost.
Clearly, Crassus needed to teach some discipline,
something he accomplished with an extreme
measure.
He revived a punishment that had not been
used for almost 200 years - decimation.
The soldiers were divided into decades - a
decade, here, simply meaning a group of ten.
They drew lots and the losing soldier from
every decade was executed.
Again, there is a bit of disagreement over
who Crassus decimated, exactly.
Plutarch said it was only one cohort of 500
or so soldiers.
Appian, however, believed it was either the
two consular legions or his entire army after
a defeat.
This is a pretty big detail because it makes
the difference between the execution of 50
soldiers, more or less, and the execution
of thousands.
Either way, the tactic seemed to work, and
Crassus showed his men that he was “more
dangerous...than the enemy”.
Victories for Both Sides
Crassus’s methods might have been harsh,
but they yielded results.
The following times that the armies met in
battle, the Romans were victorious.
Spartacus was forced to retreat to a region
in southern Italy called Lucania.
Plutarch reports that the Thracian planned
to take over the island of Sicily and regroup
there.
For this, he negotiated passage with a group
of Cilician pirates.
However, with pirates being pirates, they
double-crossed him and sailed away after being
paid.
Spartacus had his back against the wall so
he fell back to the peninsula of Rhegium.
Crassus felt that he had victory in his grasp,
but he was wise enough not to underestimate
the Thracian as many had done before him.
Instead of forcing a battle, he built fortifications
across the isthmus to the peninsula so that
the rebels would be cut off from any provisions.
Indeed, this tactic split the rebellious fighters
into two groups.
One of them broke through the siege and started
their own raiding campaign.
Crassus fell upon them swiftly and destroyed
them in battle, but he was disheartened to
see that their fighting spirit had not been
extinguished.
Although he killed over 12,000 insurgents,
upon inspection, only two of them had wounds
in their backs.
All the others had died facing their enemy,
fighting until their last breath.
Meanwhile, Crassus sent another army led by
one of his officers, Quintus, to pursue the
Spartacan forces which fled to the mountains.
The gladiator turned his troops around and
met the Romans in battle and was triumphant.
Bolstered by this recent victory, the rebels
wanted to take on the main army of Crassus.
The Arrival of Pompey
One final, decisive battle suited Crassus
just fine.
Although at first he seemed content with weakening
the insurgents as much as possible, now he
was fighting against the clock as he received
news that Roman reinforcements were on the
way.
Pompey the Great had managed to put down the
Sertorian rebellion in the Iberian Peninsula
and had redirected his forces to take on Spartacus.
Another commander named Lucullus was also
coming with additional soldiers.
You would think that the arrival of reinforcements
would be good news for Crassus, but he had
no intention of sharing credit with anyone
for putting down the largest rebellion in
Roman history.
Before making his last stand, Spartacus actually
tried to call a truce with Crassus, but the
Roman praetor rejected it categorically.
To fulfill his ambitions, nothing but the
absolute obliteration of the revolt would
have sufficed.
The armies met at the Battle of the Silarius
River.
The Spartacan troops fought hard, but were
soundly defeated.
Around 36,000 of them died in battle.
Around 6,000 more were taken prisoner by Crassus
and were all crucified along the Appian Way.
About 5,000 rebels managed to flee the battle,
but they were met by Pompey who cut them to
pieces.
Image suggestion: Appian Way
Triumph
Pompey told Rome that, even though Crassus
won the battle, he “extirpated the war”.
Accordingly, for this and his victory in Hispania,
he was given a major triumph upon his return
and made consul.
In this case, a triumph is a Roman ritual
which celebrates a general’s successes in
battle.
Crassus was later made a censor with Pompey’s
support.
He also won over the masses of Rome by using
his money to throw a giant feast in honor
of Hercules and paying for everyone’s grain
allowance for three months.
The two of them later formed an informal alliance
called the First Triumvirate alongside another
Roman up-and-comer named Julius Caesar.
The Fate of Spartacus
It would have been nice if we could have ended
with one final anecdote about Spartacus since
this bio is about him, after all.
Unfortunately, history is seldom that accommodating.
He died in battle - killed at an unknown time
by an unknown soldier - and his body was never
recovered.
Even though he had no possible way of knowing
this, Plutarch thought to provide a more fitting
end for the Thracian who tried to bring Rome
to its knees.
He claimed that, during battle, Spartacus
cut his way through the enemy ranks and tried
to reach Crassus himself, but was stopped
when two dead centurions fell upon him.
He was then completely surrounded and cut
down while fighting to the bitter end.